TOP OF HIS GAME.
HE LOOKS FRESH A
HARD MATCH.
THAT IS WHY THEY HAVE BEEN GOING
ABOUT THEIR B DEADLINE.
A FEW NIGHTS AGO AGAINST THE RED
WINGS, PICIC THE ZONE.
THE REBOUNDES HE HAVE ENOUGH JUT
IN THERE?
YES, HE
OVER THE GOAL LINE.
>> KNOWN AS ONE OF
GAMES, SEVE SEVENTH OF THE YEAR.
>> IT FEELS A LITTLE WEIRD LINE.
AND YOU SEE SIDNEY
AND IT DASON ZUCKER DOWN IN THE
AND CROSS ICE PASS, RACING AND
FINDING GREENWAYTHE HIS FOOT
AND IT'S HARD AWAY.
WITH 83. NET. THE THIRD
GAME-TYING THESE
START.
>> YES
THE PENGUINS MAINTAIN THE ZONE
AND THEY HAVE THE BETTER ZONE AY
THAT WE WANT TO PLAY
OPPORTUNITIES.
ABLE TO WIN A LOT OF BIG GAMES
IN OVERTIME JUST BECAUSE KAPRIZY
IN.
GE